[موسيقى]
هذه البقعة الملونة لها ماض مظلم
، كان لاس باميتا مكانًا خطيرًا في السابق حيث
اشتباكات بين العصابات المتنافسة ، لكن حكومة المدينة
أطلقت وتمويل مشروع
يسمى باتشوكا يرسم نفسها لتغيير
المجتمع
[الموسيقى]
، تضمنت اللوحة نفسها
مشاركة من الجميع  من الأسر
[موسيقى]
قاموا برسم أكثر من 200 منزل باستخدام 5000
جالون من الطلاء هذه
المنازل المطلية بشكل فردي مجتمعة لإنشاء
تصميم واحد جميل بألوان قوس قزح مستوحى من
الباتشوكوس الملقب بـ LA baya Arosa
للمدينة الجميلة المنسمة
وكان الهدف من المشروع هو إضفاء
الإحساس  عودة الحيوية والعيش
إلى المدينة ، لاحظت وزارة
التخطيط والتقييم لمدينة
باتشوكا أن معدل الجريمة
في المدينة قد انخفض منذ رسم اللوحة الجدارية
[موسيقى]